Remember that time when... actually no I
don't.
Hey!
Hello.
So you've got a lot to explain in an
elevator ride. Are you feeling prepared? Are you
feeling scared? I'm not afraid of you ha
ha ha ha
Maybe you should be because I'm your
limitation. I'm the one that you have to
explain everything to. No I am not scared. All right let's get started.
ha ha ha
So what is memory? Well when we
think about the brain, the brain actually
is consisting of many individual cells
that I think of like little train
stations. Ok. All these train stations are
connected to each other by tracks right
Yep. So that's the brain cells connecting
to other brain cells by synapses. So
the tracks are like synaspes. And what is
the train? So the train is like an
electrical signal. Okay. The neurons like
bing bing bing bing bing. So when we form a
memory we take something from our
environment and we put it in one of the
stations. Yeah and then you know you
recall that memory when you use that
information again. Yeah. So it's kind of
like if you have a really strong memory
then that means the connections
between two stations are really strong.
Would smarter people have more of those? So what is thought to happen is that
some people have more, like stronger
connections between many many stations
and this enables them to like remember
things really quickly. Yeah. If we
stop using those connections they get
weaker again. So how is a memory actually
stored? Like what physically is it? Yeah
so there are a lot of theories about
that. So what we think if there must be
some full of physical change in the
neurons. So like you know something is
happening in this train station because
we know that worms can remember. They're
very quite simple animals, humans can
remember. So something must be
fundamentally changing in these
neurons - so that's the brain cells - which
is not that difficult.
Right. Yeah so so worms don't have action potential. They don't have myelin which
insulates the signal from being lost but
they can still learn. So which implies
that something inside the stations are
fundamentally similar to humans or other
mammals.
We're at the halfway point. Oh no!
Do you reckon you're halfway through explaining everything that you want to tell me?
I think so.
Yes! Okay, good. Let's go!
So if they are stored as some kind of
biochemical and molecular change then if
we figure out what those changes are we
can just kind of put them back in, into
the brains of people who you know have
memory problems or you know neuro-degeneration. So theoretically if we
could find the physical thing that forms
a memory we could take it out and
transplant it?
In theory yes but we're very very far away from doing that.
So how good is the live imaging that we
have with brains? It is good but the
resolution is not fantastic we don't
look at like you know individual brain
cells so that's why we use animal models. So I used to worm because they are
transparent. I can look at each of their
brain cells individually it's pretty
cool, pretty hectic, yeah. Oh that's cool
man! So we can figure out what those you
know physical changes are in the worm
and try and translate that to humans. So
we take a complex problem and we answer
it in a simple system. Well thank you for
teaching me about memory. My pleasure.
Bye bye. Come back soon. Bye!
So if I remember correctly the brain is
made up of cells called neurons and
these are connected via synapses and
messages are sent between them through
electrical signals and these messages
are often memories which are stored
within the neurons. Now what they
actually are physically we don't quite
know yet but if we did know we would
have a much better grasp on controlling
memory. The problem in this kind of study
is that you actually need a living
subject because you need to be able to
look at whether it remembers something
before and after you manipulate it. So
that's why we look at things like
transparent worms where we can actually
look at their brains while they're still
alive. Thank you nature for creating
transparent worms! And then scaled that
kind of information up to humans and I
am so excited about this kind of study
because we've seen how impactful
diseases like Alzheimer's or dementia
can be because really our memories are
so much of what make us us? Right now
here's a memory test for you. Do you
remember our video on string theory? Well
if not here it is right there? You can
watch it again and strengthen all those
connections in your brain so you'll
remember forever.
Two for one.